it might be the chaos of the petrol
pumps making headlines but the supply
chain is being stretched at every step
a lack of skilled workers is already
delaying orders to supermarkets and
other smaller retailers
shane brennan represents businesses with
30 000 vehicles in the uk
they move chilled and frozen goods from
supplier to supermarket and have been
feeling the strain for months we're
firefighting at every stage of the
supply chain and so what that means is
that whereas we would normally pride
ourselves on being 98 order on time
we're operating around 75 80 percent
capacity
the government has tried to reassure the
public to carry on as normal but still
people are panicking for almost two
years they've experienced the trauma of
the pandemic and seen food shortages
which makes people more inclined to look
after their own
so according to experts panic buying is
a normal reaction it's been two years
nearly of constant changing of ideas and
not blaming anyone for that it's the
reality but psychologically that meant
that a lot of us feel completely out of
control of our own environment so
anything we can do whether that's
stocking up on toilet roll and lentils
and tim beans to getting petrol we're
going to do because there is a
selfishness about human beings that is
normal it's natural i want to protect my
family more than necessarily the next
family it's not that i'm not caring it's
that i care about my own first
but logistics experts say consumers will
have to change the way they behave to
stop the current crisis getting worse
what happened last year when everyone
panic bought in the grocery supply chain
in february and march is that we saw
huge amounts of food waste because
people bought way more than they needed
and they had to throw it all away and
that's just craziness we all need to
basically bet we've stuck together
through the pandemic up to now let's do
it still continue right the way through
to christmas and beyond
while plans are in place to resolve the
problems with the supply chain it will
take a long time and patience to get
fully back on track charlotte lomas sky
news